foreign
Washington D.C hi Anna welcome to the
Ramsey Show
um and I am definitely going to buy
several of those question for humans
um cards now now that I hear the same
problem so thank you for that well thank
you um I have my question is my husband
and I we have two houses one is our
primary house and the second one is our
old house that we rented out for two
years now and and my question for you is
should we keep our rental house as a
investment or should we sell it and
basically pay off our primary residence
we have 50 equity on both houses both
mortgages have three percent interest
rates we have no other debt we have a
six-month emergency fully funded kids
college and 401K is funded to the max so
what should we do
wow should we keep it as investment or
should we sell it and just pay off
basically 90 of our debt yeah you're
neither one of these answers falls in
the dumb column okay
so it's just a matter of uh good or
better and best or something like that
um so
one thing that does enter into this I
think you're probably still in the
window to sell the former residents and
qualify for a half a million dollars of
gain tax-free
if you wait another year you won't be
able to because I think it's right I
think you got two years to do that
um can't be rented more than three of
the last five years or something like
that uh whatever the number is so check
your Tax Advisor to be sure but that
would enter into the equation for me
because I can free up a half a million
dollars if I do it now tax-free
all right so that that's handy if you
wait a little while the change you know
then then we've just got an investment
property versus your residence so uh
what I personally would do because I
have
enjoyed
the peace
that comes when I don't have a single
payment in the world
and I've enjoyed the ability to build
wealth rapidly when I don't have any
payments
because of that I think it's a shortcut
I've lived it I know it's a shortcut to
sell it and pay off your house
but if you work to pay both of them off
in the next five years you're not dumb
it's just a matter of better or best
so I think best is that when you take a
gulp of air it's going to go all the way
to the bottom of your lungs when you
don't have a house payment
okay
that make any sense
yeah it does that's why I'm asking you
because my husband and I were trying to
figure that out because you know if we
sell it now then we don't have to deal
with the taxes but if we keep it then we
have to keep it for the long haul yeah
yeah you're gonna you're gonna be
landlords forever and I mean you've
already had tenants in your old house
that's an emotional event
oh well they just move and that's why
I'm calling you because now we have an
opportunity no I'm just saying when
other people moving in where you used to
sleep and live and raise your kids and
your dog is just weird
I've got one I got one of my old houses
we used to live in that we rent and it's
still and there's another house uh two
blocks over that's almost identical that
we rent that we own and I don't feel any
emotion about it and I still if the guy
doesn't Park his car right on the one I
used to live in it pisses me off still I
mean it's just weird you know it's kind
of it's kind of awkward does that make
any sense
it does
um but I love going back to my own
neighborhood and seeing my old neighbors
yeah we can do that without a house
yeah that's true
everyone who calls into the show that is
not everyone most people calling the
show who are landlord folks
um
are and Dave tell me if I'm wrong here
but they're when they are into the real
estate game and they want to be
landlords they're all in I rarely hear
somebody that's like I don't know
um it's too hard to screw with if you're
halfway it sounds like she doesn't want
to be a landlord she just doesn't want
to sell that old house no she doesn't
want to do something dumb though and you
know her friends are going oh you always
want investment real estate everybody
knows you want to investment real estate
because everybody is foolish but
everybody knows nothing that's what
everybody knows but yeah so be I mean
that's what you hear Street knowledge
just people you know your beautician has
an opinion you know she's cutting your
hair you know it's everywhere you know
and so it doesn't happen to me but
but uh but I mean you know the guy
changing your oils got investment advice
these days so they saw something on Tick
Tock so they're dead gum expert you know
and that's they're everywhere that's the
that's the thing you have and about real
estate you know you always are taught to
buy real estate you're never taught to
sell it buy always buy investment real
estate always buy a house always buy and
nobody talks about selling real estate
and there's certain there's some times
it's really good time to sell some real
estate yeah really really good time